so quick little ribbing on spark it's
relatively young it came out of a 2010
paper from groceries and left and I
highly encourage everyone to read the
paper but the gist of it is it describes
an abstraction called resilient
distributed data sets or already used
for short and well this talk will be
about already so I'll wait to elaborate
on it but going to one spark it's so
sparkles and generalized distributed
computation engine and platform based on
their hunt authority bees and what's
unique about this barrage is that you
have all powering a memory caching so
that so that data can be shared in
between workloads in a really fast
manner instead of having to read out of
a network restored such as HDFS but also
the big wave of rdd's is that it offers
a more expressive API where other
systems can build upon to really create
nice interfaces to support various
workloads such as graph analysis or
screaming or sea
so spark is really split into two
different pieces a one is the core which
is so that the corner shall share with
the jobscheduler with the interfaces
with all the various data storage
engines and then built on top of that
for our various systems such as sequel
or spark supplement to hide machine
learning grass streaming all sorts of
difference now and again this spar was
really young so I'm sure a lot more of
these little squares up top will pop up
and then the other cool thing is Python
Scala and Java are first-class citizens
it's partly so it really opens it up to
a larger audience and then our is sort
of it works but and so this is another
view of spark and how it fits into the
existing ecosystem and what you notice
is but so so we have sparked the core
engine here and then we have you know
all of the various systems that I've
showed on the previous slides but you
can also see that spark works on top of
the existing to do infrastructures such
as HDFS yarn can also go here and then
you have as a compliment Hadoop
MapReduce hi storm and all of it do
ecosystem so it's so when we talk about
spark it's not believe either spark or
Madhu they can work in the same system
and it's really about picking the best
system for the job
a little more about rdd's the so the way
IDs for describing the paper were a
read-only collection of objects
partition across a set of machines that
can be rebuilt if a partition is lost so
that sounds like a really simple thing
strange that somebody would write a
whole paper about it and then become
famous but doing this in memory is
really difficult and already became the
abstraction that allowed spark to
support and memory caching whereas
it wasn't able to be easily done but the
other really nice thing that rdd's
offered is a really expressive and
familiar scholars collections API for
doing big data analysis and that's what
I'll be focusing on in this talk not be
in memory fashion aspect and for those
of you who are culturally inclined or
let's ellezi another way of looking at
our TVs are a climatic expression of
lazy transformations except rdd's are
momentous and if you didn't so I'll be
giving a demo of how to use bark to show
you what are you these are in full and
then I'll be diving into whatever you
need and in order to do that I'll be
using this farce shell
so the sparse scale is really cool it's
built on top of the Scala shell and what
it allows you to do is perform
large-scale queries interactively you'll
see that and it's just amazing for
prototyping or really just analyzing
your data in a very quick and the other
nice thing is
you can run spark you complete spark
show have your look of those Canada swum
multiple grass and analyze your data but
you can also put it added yarn cluster
so you can be issuing commands to
thousands of change into your cluster to
perform analysis and same for visa and
it has all the advantages a big
marshmallow such a static type checking
and autocomplete because it really sucks
when you have a job money for hours and
then turns out you have a syntax error
and as you also see Spock really shows
off why Scala is different than why it's
really useful compared to let's say Java
or a couple of other languages and in a
specific case you'll see how score makes
really interesting use of land us to
create a really concise API moving data
analysis so just going back to our
previous diagram home jump through most
of these components so we'll be looking
at the course our API first so here's a
basic spark shop and I'll just walk
through it quickly we load a text file
from this foreign context which is what
SC's ends for so SC just contained for
example the authentication or HDFS how
to connect a yard whether it's local or
not
so just the execution content and then
we just noted a text file called title X
2 XP which is on my computer but you can
also just throw in an HDFS mate or the
loaded out of HDFS and when you see this
it it almost looks like we're just
working with a in-memory Scala
collection I mean we have just we just
flat back over it this this is your
general word count example so we just
work through the list of titles we flat
map it to
trackage the words out we map it into a
tuple of the first word and then an
integer so that we can reduce over into
sum over the last parts so that we did a
count per word and then here is just
more filtering since warfighters again
syntax is extremely similar to Scala but
in the background all of this can be
running in parallel on thousands of
machines on the on cluster so I mean
this Titan how simple the API is it's
doing a lot of work so how I'm just
going to open up the smart shell and
just run these commands so this is on a
Vitelli mark installation so really not
doing anything special here so I just
loaded up the titles and
anyway we're just going to define
organize which splits a title so the
titles are separated by underscores each
word within the title separate about
underscore so we're just going to split
it and so we'll get a list of words and
so for example if we pass this in but we
get this and now we defined another
function called cleanse and what this
does is it removes all the weird
characters it removes really any other
character any not so that when we do our
reduce you won't have a different word
for a capitalized does we pass a word
with the capitalization to come at the
end and it just spits out a lowercase so
now so used to spark and so when we
moated the title into the titles
variable it created an RDD
and so what we did here is just call
five tokenized and then we cleanse each
word and then we reduce entry caches and
how this happened really quickly and
we're actually working on a pretty
decent data size about 6 billion titles
all of the titles in the English
Wikipedia so what happened here is that
nothing actually happened other than to
spark aggregating a lot of these
computations to run later
so I so now when we actually might help
this is so what I did was I ran the
first command first and then I ran the
second command now the second command is
slightly different in the first command
as this month at the end which is which
means I will perform all of these
calculations on the roof these remote
machines but then pass it all on to the
wolf machine and what luck will do is
close the entire computation to be run
and what you'll see is we called collect
it returns back a a list of all the word
to count mappings as tuples and this is
just
so that's pretty cool we were able to
just do a pretty logical computation
again you know instead of titles being
six billion lines imagine that being
hundreds of millions if not billions of
lines and you know these computations
instead of being scaled out with read my
own machine being scaled out the threads
on the arm and you can see why why this
API is really powerful for despite how
supportive and so yeah paying more
principle behind the already B's is that
you have two different sort of functions
one is the transformation which all it
does is its it it's transforms the data
in some way so either mapping it or
joining up or sorting it then you matter
and then so when you apply
transformations spa doesn't do anything
it just aggregates those transformations
inside they already eat so that then
when you perform an action command such
as asking page and I have everything in
each rdd's on my local computer it knows
the entire graph of those
transformations and can optimize it so
that it can avoid a lot of extra work
so that's that's it just the spark API
again it's it's just really
straightforward there's really not much
to it that looks surprisingly like the
questions so no we don't want to show
you why already these are really
interesting and that's and so I'll be
demoing the sparse typi next and it's
again it's complementary to hide in that
sense that up
there's my to accomplish similar things
which is being able to execute sequel on
large clusters of data in HDFS so here's
a quick demo on what it takes to create
a schema in sparse equal so we
initialize the context for sequel and
then the interesting thing is we don't
have to define our schema at all all you
have to do is define a case class
containing the column names and the
column types and spark will
automatically enter the column names and
types so that you can do sequel phrase
over here so super cool a lot of magic
happens in the background so what we do
here is previously we have a tuple of
all the caps from the word to well look
the word itself and then how many times
the word
appear in the titles file and so we just
turned that into a face class beyond
this math function again at this point
this is all rdd's so this is all still
operating the 10 serum over change there
and then what we do here is now that
we've imported this single context we
just added a ton of new functionalities
rdd's specifically sequel dsls such as
where select and select so now you can
perform sequel operations in the DSO
manner on rdd's and again this is really
cool because we haven't done much work
here all we did was really turn an RDD
into a I just map turning already data
to a collection of state classes and we
were able to query the RDD with a sequel
TSM so I'll just this
and then and now from my previous else
from tuples into his classes and now
what I do is execute a sequel DSL on it
and as you'll see the output 116 which
is the number of times Scala the word
Scala your name
so the dsl is nice but I think a lot of
people still get for tech screws and
it's again it really trivial to load
rdd's or transform rdd's so that they
can support expertise so all we do is we
just call register 10 table on our RDD
give at the table thing and now we can
just call this single function that was
imported from the sequel contest pass it
in just a single trade exactly matching
the sequel for the query expressed in
the sequel DSL to report and then we
call again collect on it so it'll
execute it and you know so these two are
exactly the same what sparks equal does
in the background is it'll parse a
sequel and then transform it into the
spark or API something that can be
executed of a small spark or API so very
similar to what I does when it takes in
sequel and then converts it into
MapReduce jobs again I'll just
so we better start table and now we can
just execute again we get 1:16 back and
just execute the so this is e what the
sequel query gets turned into and again
the same Scala the same spark API that I
was showing you earlier to spark core
API so oh okay
and so sports people can actually do a
lot more so one so the next thing is
well what if we want user defined
functions expressman spark sequel well
that's really easy you just call
register function give it the function
name and then what you want the function
to do and then you can just refer to it
in your string sequel so as you see we
i'm length which come in to link to the
string so now in our single query we can
filter we can query for all the words
with a length of 10 and then there's a
couple of other statements to show that
that supports you know most of the
sequel statements so you have your
devise limits etc and again and again
when it ends up getting turned into is a
spark or API query
so the other thing to know is you know
we may not wear our Dedes everything
complex so it didn't actually execute
anything and now what we can do is this
is still an RDD so you can still apply
to all of your other transformations on
it such as map filter all of them so the
spark or you guys all still and this is
a truly powerful because previously you
know at least in the Hadoop ecosystem
all of these infrastructures separate so
when you query for something at hide you
have to save it at HDFS and then read it
out of you know you have your MapReduce
jobs now all of your computations can be
together in a single file and what makes
it even better it is none of this has to
be persistent here immediately on to
HDFS so you get huge performance
increases since this all just lives on
the memory of your execute executors and
so all we do here is simple map we map
the lead so what we care for is all
words of like edge sorted by the number
of occurrences and so we just want to
display what those top ten words are and
how many times that how many times they
appeared in the titles transformations
do you have the ability to append yes
that's actually exactly what's going on
here is until you call an action like
collect or save it to a file nothing
happens so you can append to it as much
as you want and then what else what
spark will do is once you call an action
on the RTE and as I'll show later the
RTD knows all the actions prior all the
change actions to it and then it'll you
know do its fancy stuff and schedule the
jobs accordingly
demo when I registered the function and
so again here I didn't execute the
sequel and what it fitted out was just a
execution plan much like you notice from
more sequencing pull and then you know
where you already bees what we get back
it's just an RDD of the sequel great and
so we just map over that which and then
we call a top left on it so the job
actually runs and as you'll see we get a
count of all the words with ten
characters and the number of appearances
in the titles sorted by the number of
appearances
good question so let me go back that's
essentially a good distinction so okay
well one of the problem or one of the
things you'll run into initially with
it's partly is the sports API is so
similar to Scala collections API that
sometimes you just accidentally start
running like these huge computations of
under named driver by accidents that are
parallelizing it so the thing to know is
anytime before
anytime before you take an action or a
call an actual commands such as collect
for any of the things I listed nothing
happens so anything before that gets
distributed parallel in parallel but
once I call select it pulls everything
down into the main spark driver node
which has a scheduler and everything
else on it and now so when I'm called up
for each on it it runs it locally so
it's not paralyzed so yeah you don't
have to be careful about that good
question for in each was not but
everything else above collect was so for
example you know the word filtering
length the sorting the limit and then
the naphtha also so the intimacy
operation
yes so the intermediate that's correct
so the intermediate operations are as if
let's say you wrote okay
let's distribute it to all machines yes
so you can actually call that for each
for each s also an action so I actually
love to collect here because so far
collect has been D action so I wanted to
clear so many but yeah you can also do
dock will eat vanilla in it yeah there's
there's a lot here so for one spark
doesn't execute any of these steps until
you call the last action so for example
I don't know how detailed I should get
but shuffles are really expensive in to
do and there are a certain case where
you shuffle the data around so that in
between stages so that you know you get
better partitioning and so on what spark
will do is it'll create a graph of these
jobs from what you passed in through the
rdd's and it knows when to for example
not do shuffles or want to even perform
multiple steps on the same machine so
that everything is the memory already
and again you know this is for example
when you just call a simple map it if
you just call if you just chain multiple
maps together there's no reason that has
to be splitted up into multiple stages
versus if you call a joint that requires
I guess shuffle isn't a lot of work to
be done so
that sort of answers your question
partially so we particularly was
wondering in your first example you
first collected the popular words and
then your filters Blancos lengua one of
the pipe symbols so it was hard to be
able to push that filter to before I can
group them ah no it's not that far
unfortunately so so the course part api
may not be able to do it but if you if
you look at sparks equal I think spar
sequel has its own great optimizers so I
think it does that although the query
optimizer is still a little immature as
and you can probably read through most
of the program see exactly like those so
there's there's still work to be done
I'm at you by about to get to that
so everything after collect so when you
call it left squawk just turns the are
you need into an enemy array so anything
after that it's it's cereal because
after the collect is me it's just all
quite dozens if it says give me all the
data it is already in a ready format on
the local machine
no you dump so if if we go back one of
the one of the action is same as the
text file - especially if you do in a to
HDFS I don't know what did I think if
you put a lot more path there don't just
save the text font that each of the
individual those which you know gonna
ask you one more film session you said
that you are looking at streaming data
because you are doing often interactive
analysis know if there is streaming data
the RVT volume has security yes that's a
really good point and I'm right about
the pocket value because streaming is a
whole different paradigm do you write it
so we can't do any of this or at least
account we have to do more and that's
what scar streaming is all about is we
have the course park API but there just
seems need more infrastructure than
handle streaming data so especially make
a compliment storm so there's no tasks
you have the stream of incoming data and
you want to you know do carry almost
real-time analysis and similarly you
know you want all of this to be fault
tolerant so spark a know that
it'll take the input speed and copy it
onto the multiple machines so that you
know if the machine parsing the stream
fails it can move the job too much
information and another interesting
thing is and this is getting more
specific is what do you have when you
have streaming data you know typically
the only way you still have to partition
it somewhat the smallest being will each
individual data point to larger batches
so what's part of what's part reaming
does is it that's the data rdd's but
another interesting use case is well in
a lot of cases when we do streaming you
want to do longer-term computation such
as how many times did we see this hash
tag within the past hour but we want to
know that value on a permanent basis so
we need some sort of window or well I
want this to run X number of times per
minute but I also want the window to the
excise those are very different values
so so what's part we'll do is when you
and I'll show you the you care of it is
what would you when you do a filter or
when you do any sort of transformations
on sparse singing output which is called
a DSP which is a batch or collection of
rdd's those rdd's are split into your
time intervals plus the whole window so
for example if your if your time
interval is a per minute run you can
have a window that's 60 minutes so each
bath will have 60 data points or 60 RTD
it's a snapshot but still not the target
right
going back in book format
I guess it's it's pretty much what
everybody uses HDFS
so with HDFS it just constantly the test
if you've added a new file and again the
API is really simple so sparse streaming
has a special utility for Twitter
because that makes the most really easy
but again as you can see at the end of
the day we still get back a set of our
Dedes that we can do our transformations
on so that's what this filter is about
but as you'll see in this case you know
we also want a so five seconds is
helping tomatoes are really
straightforward very minimal work and so
that's spark screening just going over
streaming graph and ml link really
quickly but this is just to show you how
our didi can be extended in these
various or two ways for different uses
so next we're gonna talk about graphics
which is a parallel graph from do and so
what graphics does is you pass it in our
DVDs containing two bowls of the
vertices and edges and it'll optimally
partition and index your graph so that
you can do triple traversals
and various other dungeon so offers an
API to you know combine join grass and
traverse them and it also has just
predefined functions that you can run on
a graph PageRank components triangle
County
just be useful and again it's really
easy to do once it's really easy to do
so you make a graph out of your nose and
your links and then once you have a
graph you can just call that a think on
it and get the vertices out which again
are just party need so ranks is just an
RDD
and so typically when you do these large
graph transformations you want to
minimize the data stored in each node
since again you want a lot of this to be
within a memory so will typically leave
out a label so that the Millis are just
an integer what we can do that is
because ranks is just an RDD
we can just read out the labels from a
text file put it into another heartie
bead and then join the two rdd's
together and then at the end of the day
what we have is the page ranks with the
vertice ids joined by the ids in our
text file
so again just because of the fact that
you know graphics return to rdd's we are
able to do this operation really easily
and again in a single file and last of
all there's Emily which is a machine
learning library and it serves a similar
role to my house and so as many of you
probably could use my help realize but
how one's really slowly depending on
which time would you pick especially the
data rate at once and the reason being
is Hadoop will state intermediate
computations on to HDFS which is a
really
computation so machine learning is
actually one of the best use cases for
spark right now where you know you can
easily see performance increases of 10x
of you are gonna make sense because
instead of saving into a network store
the in between each computation is it
all already lives in memory and so it's
a pretty new library so it doesn't have
the whole block old set of capabilities
that my hat but it's still a decent
amount and again they're working on
adding a lot more so you have you know
your regular systems like me Maryann's
progressions decision trees clustering
analysis gradient descent and again all
of these are paralyzed so again like
mihalick it's really nice that machine
learning experts put in the time of
creating these libraries for you so that
you can just run it easily on a large
data set without really knowing how it's
in the back and this is what I was
saying earlier machine learning
assisting is a great resource because
the for the yeah Oh actually show you so
the data set are again all expresses
rdd's as you go so so again it really
depends on what you're training over
like oh so there's no reason why you
can't write a 500 megabyte computation
on it but yeah yeah here's the thing at
least from my perspective is what's
stopping you from using a this overkill
system mics are on a smaller data set is
how you interact with it so for example
my house takes a lot of work to set up
as well as the rest of the Duke
ecosystem or as you can just download a
spark run of locally and you get asked
all of this
so in some sense there's no reason not
to use it before a small data set but if
the performance is critical I'm guessing
you're going to be able to get much
better performance out of more non
distributed systems focused on it and I
can't tell you a specific number because
I think across the board but I would I
would say like easily yeah and I think
that's a great point that the API you
use here are very similar to the classes
API which can be considered small data
so it really lowers a bar for the amount
of effort it takes to take advantage of
a large system such as yarn
from a programmers perspective or
developers so this is a sample emmalin--
demo and so again we load some data into
an RDD and so this is a linear
regression example these are just x and
y's we have training data which is which
we turn into a haze class of label
points so that we can feed it into the
linear regression training model again
really simple that's why and when we
feed it in we just pass it in our parse
data and then the number of iterations
and we get back a model and now what we
want to know is well how accurate is our
model so then what we can do is we go
back to the original parse data and then
we map all the points and just call a
predict so model doc predict on it so
use our models to predict the same
points that we already have and then
what we can do is just do some simple
math and calculate the mean square error
to get a general sense of how you use it
basically I'm gonna say you divide like
yes not in this case so you're talking
about validation but in this case
without three validation we're just
calculating mean square error which
which shows us how good of a fit the
linear regression is so for example you
know our data may not be linear
I'm not familiar with ever so secret
since you have to shave
yes you can so that that's one of the
big wins spark to it you have all of
these libraries that has input as
already and outputs are needy and all of
these party do you have this unified API
map filtering all of that so to answer
your question yes I don't think well we
might be talking about different things
then because what I thought your
question was was just lets us talk
offline about it because I think you're
asking about something so I just gave
you guys a quick tour of the entire
spark ecosystem starting with the base
farm API and the variety of different
systems built on top of that spark 80 I
have to support unique workflows so now
that you've seen our Dedes connection I
want to go back and talk about how our
Dedes are infinitely because again it
looks like a lot of magic people just
earlier and so said take that bone out a
little bit further for those of you who
understand nomads you can almost look at
an ordinary as a modem and encapsulate
the iterator so at the core of each RTE
is the data that's associated with it
and it's expressed as a lazy iterator
that you can call it not mathlete
filters so as you'll notice all the
spark api's are functions
you can apply to an iterator but having
an integrative iterators isn't good
enough because we're talking about
distributed system here so we have to so
an already B also has to contain
metadata about how the data your video
rating over is partition so for example
without this data
there's no way to 1 there's no way if
we're spartan distribute Java and
something else that you need when you
talk about the system that hashes caches
calculations and memory is doing it in a
fault-tolerant fashion so what happens
so for example if you're not saving
intermediate data in HDFS if that
particular machine crashes in the middle
of the execution how do you get all of
that data back so what SPARC does is as
you can see from our de there's a lot of
chaining there's a lot of metadata so
and then you give the moment SPARC knows
how to reconstruct all the stuff and to
where it failed on the original dataset
which is how it's able to avoid storing
intermediate data again lacy evaluated
in the lab operation expressions because
you're not exceeding
and when adding operation of our Natick
operations similar to an algebraic
operations okay so so it's not gonna so
party days are not automatic at all in
the flat map definition it's just
complete long I didn't want to explain
though I'm asked because I know I can't
so this is more thickened as if you
double as this parallel might be useful
but if you don't then don't worry about
it okay so yeah this this is a feature
of spark that I don't talk about in my
talk but there's a concept in
checkpointing so you can use them
something similar to what padukas and
say to a reliable stores such as HDFS
but the idea is to not do it of every
single sense that's possible so here's a
visualization on is how rdd's been
executed so you have security already
query we have a choice - goodbye
filter so the join we're joining the top
two boxes into an a group body and then
the filter operations right here so as
you'll see from a hearty B perspective
it's just a directed acyclic graph of
computational jobs that it has to do so
for example you know in order to do this
step sparkles to perform both of the
jobs above first so that's a lot of what
the scheduler handles but what you see
here are just single RTD objects and
again it abstract surround the entire
distributed nature of your computation
which is you know splitting each of
these tasks up to thousands of machines
so in fact what you actually have is
each of the rdd's continue multiple
partitions
and the various transformations such as
your maps are executed on each of the
partitions and then passed on to the
next or DD so how did that happen and so
it turns out and already is a really
simple thing it's just an interface and
department so that sparks jobscheduler
and the engine can execute these these
paths so in order to find our DD you
need to define start so I'm just going
to go ahead into my IDE and go to our
native Scala and inside this farm source
code and so what you'll see
okay so what you'll see here is this is
the ethnic class WD and here are the
three things that varies rdd's implement
so compute which is yeah show
computation that's being done so if
you're calling dot map with a function
it'll have there and then partition is
how you want to partition your data so
for example for HD if your data in HDFS
then the most sensible partition scheme
is partitioning the data into HDFS
blocks and then dependencies is what
stores all the historical information so
what you saw in the graph and my
previous slide where you can follow a
child are to eat all the way back up to
its parents to be able to recalculate
all the data
so yeah all it is are these big
functions and so let's just walk through
some details so when we call that text
file to load a text file and that will
computer into an RDD the money that it
generated is called a new party and so
adieu party need generalizes over text
but it can also obviously support HDFS
lost with special optimizations for it
so in the case of the Hadoop RTD the
compute is just reading the HDFS block
or a section of the file if towards
hippler you have like a multi gigabyte
file this farm will automatically split
into that let's say one gigabyte chunks
so that you can easily run parallel
computations over it and so gap
partitions is you know what defines a
partition split so spark will either
give it a file level or as whether it's
block and there are no defenses because
it's each source in fact we can
there's a lot of stuff going on here but
you'll see there's get partitions which
is pretty simple it just most of the who
do difficult format simplicity and
participatory me and then you have to
compute which just leads me meets the
file HDFS and then get dependencies here
so now when we call a dock map on the
RTD that we receive it returns an apt
RTD so that map already contains the
computation for that map so it contains
the function that you're mapping over
and the facts have your bathroom or
something so for the complete part it
has to compute the parent the result of
the Karen Hardy DS so a call stop
compute on its parent and then it just
calls a dot map of containing the
function of the result of the parent
computation and then for yet partition
it just partitions accordingly to its
parent so for example for your homie
atomic mass on a I do RTD it just
partitions FS plus and then get
dependencies it's just a single
dependency off its parent it's just a
one to one relationship okay so the math
or DD is surprisingly simple I'm going
to go to the math function on the RTD so
that's the function you actually call
you call it dot map in the
yes it tries to be I mean you can have
our purchase you can have our partitions
and executors if you run out of
executors but yes if if there are enough
executors or partitions then they should
be so we just call that and as you see
in math we pass in a function that we
want it to be back over and all spark
does is it creates this new map or you
need passing it the function so there is
so cleanest a bit of an implementation
detail because you know in your function
you might have a closure so you need to
close over all of your variables and
send it over the network or else the
variable you're referencing and your
closure won't be available on these
remote machines so that's what clean
does is it packages of this function
basically so when we're going to the map
rdd's there's nothing special
yet partitions we just get the partition
of our parent no we always assume
there's only one and therefore compute
we calculate our parent and then that
returns back an iterator that we just
call dot map with the function over it
so really nothing in T going on here
really surprising straightforward
so that we have a code group RDD which
is what happens when you call join again
when you call compute now it has to do a
lot more work it has to calculate each
of its parents shuffle it and then and
then combine the rdd's of its shuffle
combined this off of our shuffle rdd's
of its parents and then get partitions
is this one per reduce task which is a
configuration variable that infested and
the dependencies is each of the parents
that okay so in summary part of these
offer rdd's is the abstraction that
allows form and the very system building
on top of it to offer developers but
really clean nice and even applied API
that also allows a lot all of these
systems to each other the one of the big
winners here is because it's in Scala
and the fact that it's Java really
quickly you can do interactive analysis
um really large ESS and it has amazing
paducah integration so for example SPARC
is not officially supported that event
but because we have a young cluster and
we we can just point spark to Ariane
cluster and everything works even though
there is no explicit support response
and again because it it's able to
leverage in memory caching to get a lot
of squeeze a lot of effort again
references these slides will be posted
online so these are things to check out
on the original smart paper of talks on
it and then already decide to look into
and yeah that's a good question so I'm
actually talking of infrastructure
people are PayPal to acquire larger
machines with much larger memory to
support sparkler clubs so that's
definitely true although you can just
run it on a regular renewed cluster and
not really get a much performance tip
because it will just spill over to disk
and the nice thing about sparring
there's a rack on it but even if your
entire computation cannot fit in memory
you still get incremental speed ups if
parts of it can fit in memory because
sparkly make certain optimizations a
couple of slides showing some code yes
before that where there's a lineman save
that computed new already be with the
new operation I don't think there was a
bunch of stuff what do you want to just
look at it offline sure sure
but my question is does it an operation
change the RBZ no so rdd's are immutable
so when you call a dot app on it it just
generates a new martini with a link to
the parent
and the meet ability is just huge in a
distributed systems because there's
nobody saying all of this and if you
lose it you can recover it because
they're so you mentioned that guys that
worked on the one of the slides is it
possible to have like an invitation that
were one of those steps is an API step
for example I imagine some of the linear
algebra operations come with learning
are probably yeah so that's definitely
possible and that's so I would encourage
you to have this pharmacy cocoa because
they have to do something similar right
where they have to take a sequel query
and it's not just a one to one
translation there's a lot of room for
optimization in the execution plan so
they do some tricks with how they call
get dependency and stuff like that so
that it's executed in their own way
outsiders so it takes good to do though
using spark shuffle yep we can talk
yeah so there are organizations in that
regard so it and we'll try to put
iterative stuff and memories so that in
the simplest way that capsule works is
it's the least recently used but I just
believe there are our optimizations so
that if you're iterating over a ton of
stuff it will be bit